Speaker 1: I want to start today talking about
Afghanistan again, and I almost feel inclined
like I need to start with some general concepts
that maybe some of us aren't totally comfortable
with. I know I am comfortable with a few
of these ideas. Let me give you an example.
Something can be the right strategy, but
executed with the wrong tactics. Something can be
mostly good, but not 100 percent. Something can be
carried out mostly correctly, but not 100 percent.
And we can still say that it's mostly good without
ignoring or devaluing the ways in which it is not
so good. These are seemingly simple concepts, but
many of my colleagues on the left and of course
the people on the right are completely in bad
faith. But many of my colleagues on the left seem
unable or unwilling to understand
this. Joe Biden has decisively. Ended
a 20 year war that was the right decision
for the last 20 years, there has been
less scrutiny about what we have been doing in
Afghanistan than over the last two weeks in terms
of the mistakes that were made getting out and
there were mistakes made. There's no need to hide
that. You don't have to pretend that everything
was done perfectly to still make the moral case
and the geopolitical case and the economic case
for it being the obviously right decision to get
out of Afghanistan. And I have to tell you, Joe
Biden did it decisively and he did it as honestly
as I've seen politicians do it. Joe Biden, again,
addressed the nation yesterday and he said,
I take responsibility for the things that
didn't go right. Remember the last guy, the
former guy? I don't take responsibility at all.
It would have gone perfectly. Later in the show,
we're going to look at an interview that Trump
did yesterday where he was actually given the
opportunity to say, what exactly would you have
done differently in Afghanistan? It's not clear
he would have done anything differently. It's
just posturing from these clowns on the right.
But I have a hard time remembering a
time when a president was this decisive
about getting us out of an intervention. We've
seen them be decisive, getting us in, but getting
us out is a different story. So let's go right
to it. Joe Biden addressing the nation yesterday.
Speaker 2: I made a commitment to the
Speaker 1: American people that we
have here. Hold on a second. We have. Why
can't I hear that? That is are. Here we go.
All right. Let's take it from the top.
Speaker 2: I made a commitment to the
American people that I would end this
war today. I'm honored that commitment.
It was time to be honest with the American people
again. We no longer had a clear purpose in an open
ended mission in Afghanistan right after 20 years
of war in Afghanistan. I refuse to send another
generation of America's sons and daughters to
fight a war. It should have ended long ago.
Speaker 1: This is something the Trumpet's
claimed to agree with when it was Trump's plan,
and this is something the leftists have
been saying all along. And yet people don't
seem too happy with what Joe Biden has done.
Speaker 2: After more than two trillion dollars
spent in Afghanistan costs, the researchers
at Brown University estimated it would be over
three hundred million dollars a day for
20 years in Afghanistan for two decades.
Yes, the American people to hear this 300 million
dollars a day for two decades. You take the number
of one trillion, many say that's still a hundred
and fifty million dollars a day for two decades,
what have we lost as a consequence in terms
of opportunities? I refuse to continue the
war that was no longer in the service of
the vital national interest of our people.
Speaker 1: This is one of the most anti-war
speeches we've heard from a president in decades.
Speaker 2: But most of all, after 800000
Americans serve in Afghanistan, I traveled that
whole country brave and honorable service after
twenty thousand seven hundred forty four American
servicemen and women injured and the loss of
two thousand four hundred sixty one American
personnel, including 13 lives lost
just this week. I refuse to open
another decade of warfare in Afghanistan.
Speaker 1: This is one of the most decisive
anti-war actions and statements from
a president. Let's listen to a little
bit more. This was a very good speech.
Speaker 2: I was not going to extend this
forever war. And I was not extending
a forever exit, right, the decision
to end the military left operations at Kabul
Airport was based on unanimous recommendation
of my civilian and military advisers, the
secretary of state, the secretary of defense,
the chairman of the Joint Chiefs
of Staff and all the service chiefs
and the commanders in the field.
Speaker 1: Was the exit executed perfectly?
No. Were the people there told more than a
month ago, we want to start getting you out?
Yes. Would it have gone perfectly if Joe Biden had
done it differently or if Trump had done it? No,
there is no perfect way to get out. What happened
was, to some degree inevitable, but it could
have been handled better. But this is the right
decision. Let's watch a little bit more of this.
Speaker 2: To those asking for a third
decade of war in Afghanistan, I ask,
what is the vital national interest?
Right. In my view, we only have one.
To make sure Afghanistan can never be used
again to launch an attack on our homeland,
Speaker 1: that's that's what sorry, that
is extremely decisive. And then lastly, I'm
concerned about the people left in Afghanistan as
well. There's very few in terms of the Americans,
more than one hundred thousand Afghans have been
helped out of the country. It's never perfect,
but a lot of the right things are being done now.
Speaker 2: We believe that about 100 or 200
Americans remain in Afghanistan. With some
intention to leave. Most of those who remain
are dual citizens, long time residents who had
earlier decided to stay because of their family
roots in Afghanistan. The bottom line,
90 percent of Americans in Afghanistan
who wanted to leave were able to leave.
Speaker 1: Listen, this is not a guy who's acting
like his approval rating is the most important
thing. This is an individual who has decided
that morally, geopolitically and financially it's
time to go. This is not an incursion that after
20 years serves the interests of the United
States. And that is the job of the president.
And he is saying, I am ending it and he is taking
a hit to some degree and his approval rating. But
he's not wavering and it's the right decision
and we're going to keep talking about it. Now,
what has been disgusting to see is that the
corporate media, now that Biden ended this war,
seems to be asking, when's the next war? Might
we go back into Afghanistan? We're going to be
looking at some of the questions asked in
yesterday's press briefing with Jen Psaki
right after this speech. And it really seems
like corporate media just wants us to stay in to
stay for a while. Some of them have motives of not
seeming partizan and holding Biden to account, but
with very dumb questions. And then you've got the
sort of bad faith right wingers I saw yesterday.
What's this guy's name? Ben Shapiro, who
was retweeting just like little out of
context bits and pieces of the speech to
make it seem like Biden just doesn't care
about what's going on with the people in
Afghanistan, both Americans and Afghans,
and an extremely bad faith. Pratik, some doing the
Biden dimentia stuff. Biden made errors in how the
pullout was handled. There's no question about it.
The buck stops with Biden, even if it was on the
basis of how others lower down in the food chain
handled it. There was no perfect path out. He took
responsibility and he's owning it. But this was
George W. Bush's hairbrained incursion. Obama
didn't get us out. Trump didn't get us out.
Biden got us out, and that's the big story.